Let's give it up
(audience clapping)
for the winners of the prestigious,
Teacher of the Year Award.
Yay! Woo!
(audience cheering)
From Washington D.C. it's Dominique Foster.
(upbeat music)
(clapping)
And from Connecticut, it is Kim King.
(audience cheers)
And from New York, it is Jen Waugh.
(clapping)
Oh my gosh, teachers of the year.
Wow!
Oh my gosh.
Brandice, would you be so kind
as to tell us about these looks?
Absolutely.
So Drew, you know that every time I come here,
I have on a blazer.
That is my thing.
And so I love this blazer on her.
We just talked to some of the teachers a second ago
about how a blazer really almost makes you feel
like you have on an armor.
It makes you feel so powerful
and pairing this with like a mini skirt and these loafers
just kind of make sure that
the look is totally complete.
And then a scarf can change any look.
So without the scarf, she'd have on a denim shirt
and these beautiful pink pants,
but the scarf really ties it all together nicely
with that print.
So the prints, as you know, are so huge.
Prints are always great for the springtime
and this print looks absolutely beautiful on her.
You guys look
so stunning.
So good.
I mean, honestly.
So good!
(audience applauds)
And finally, I would love to introduce a husband
and wife teacher duo.
Yes!
They wanted
a little refresh.
So here is Jersey's Teacher of the Year,
Angel Santiago, come on out.
(lighthearted music)
(audience claps)
Woo!
How do you feel?
And don't look that way because your wife is there
and we're revealing her as a surprise.
How do you feel?
I feel great.
I mean, this outfit's me.
I love it.
I feel awesome, I feel great in this outfit.
Okay.
And are you ready to see your wife?
Absolutely!
Been waiting all day.
Please, welcome Courtney.
Yeah!
(audience cheers and claps)
Oh my gosh!
Mwah! (lips smack)
Hi!
You look good.
Wow!
Thank you.
(audience cheers and claps)
Wow, wow.
May I ask when you met, were you both teachers?
We were.
Yeah.
We were teachers, yeah.
I think we were.
We both started the same year.
So were you like, oh my God, I'm a teacher.
Oh my God, you're a teacher and...
(audience laughs)
Talk to him.
Yeah.
Actually I was a musician.
So I met her at a, you know, at one of our shows
and we're like--
And then you're like, oh my God,
I'm gonna become a teacher.
Yeah, yeah exactly, yeah.
(laughing)
Can you just tell me really quickly one thing
you admire about each other's teaching?
I think for my wife,
she deals with a population, the special ed population.
And you know, she puts her heart and soul.
She treats those kids like they're her own,
and she's a fantastic mother,
so it shows in her classroom as well.
Aw!
(Drew sighs)
Thanks.
(audience claps)
Oh my God.
(Courtney laughs)
And Courtney?
Yes.
With Angel, I mean, sometimes it drives me crazy,
but his dedication to his students, his craft,
obviously Teacher of the Year
is like the highest accolade ever.
So, super proud of him.
His dedication is unmatched.
So, thank you so much for this opportunity.
It was great day together.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, everybody's been asking me
what I'm doing after the show,
but Chris, what did you do with the hair?
Your hair's stunning.
You know, we've done lots throughout
the process, of lightening hair,
we've cut hair, we've added shape and texture.
A lot of it was honestly just
about the quality of the hair though.
A lot of women struggle these days
with keeping good qualities of the hair
just 'cause we're constantly changing it and evolving it.
Whether the hair's color treated,
whether your hair's straight, curly, texturized
whatever it is, it's about getting
a great finish to the hair.
And that's kind of, I guess what I became known for
is what I do with hair.
Whatever it is, it has that quality
and now a lot of that is just about styling
and using products to actually, you know,
make your hair look much better without a lot of work.
So obviously, everyone leaves today with the Dream Coat
but that's my go-to product.
It transforms the texture of hair on all heads of hair,
curly, straight whatever it is
and gives you that really kind of,
you know more looks finish.
You saw when we walked out,
it was kind of bouncy and glossy
and you feel like you just wanna swing it around.
A lot of that is just about transforming
the hair with products.
And quite often, we forget about that, you know?
So I think it's really important to have the tools
to recreate these looks at home as well.
It's true.
I always forget products.
I do.
(audience claps)
Charlotte, what else did you do?
Well, I just wanna show you this
because this is my multi miracle.
This is a multi glow.
And when you put this on top of the cheekbones,
I don't know if you can see that there in the camera
but how that just gives you
that dream sheen glass-like glow skin
that's like smooths out any pores, any fine lines
'cause it's a new technology and you put it down the center
of the nose a little bit on the top of the lip.
And that just gives you that lifts your cheek bones.
I feel like it also grabs that light.
It does.
It's a night thing.
And throws it on your face.
Yes!
And says, look at me.
Yes.
(audience laughs)
(clapping)
Yes! (Charlotte laughs)
Oh you guys, I cannot thank you enough.
I mean the one and only Charlotte Tilbury,
the magnanimous Brandice Daniel and Chris Appleton,
our dear friend and hair stylist extraordinaire
and most importantly,
our 25 incredible game-changing teachers.
Yeah!
Woo!
(cheering and clapping)
I also wanna thank Chillhouse for doing the nails
and finally, a huge thank you to Talbots, a company
I've recently had the pleasure of working with
and they provided all the clothes today
and they're giving $150 gift certificate
to all the teachers.
Oh my gosh!
Wow!
(cheering and clapping)
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
(whispers) Thanks, everybody. (laughs)
Aw.
Thanks so much.
(voice choking)
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
(vocalizing)